dily wire has this report the US
government is not being fully
transparent about what it means about
UFOs according to a journalist who just
wrote a book on the topic Garrett graph
author of UFO the inside story of the US
government's search for alien life here
and out there shared insights into his
work as as uh into his work during an
interview on NBC news with uh host Chuck
Todd let's watch a little bit of that
interview what is one thing you've
learned about UFOs that the public
doesn't know of
well I think there are a couple of
things that stand out for me right at
the top here um the first as you covered
in some of the previous segment that
there is something real here there are
things out there in our airspace that we
do not understand what they are um and
that those could represent uh Exquisite
new adversary technology but they could
also represent science that we don't
understand atmospheric meteorological
and astronomical science that we don't
yet understand and that I believe that
there are the government is covering up
some level of its knowledge and
understanding about what some of those
things are um you know both in in terms
of what chunk of that is our
government's own secret development
programs uh you know planes drones new
technologies that we're working on as
well as what were sensing and detecting
of advanced adversary
technology uh you know being tested
against US forces uh or around us
airspace um what I'm unconvinced of is
that the government is covering up
meaningful
knowledge of uh you know alien
spacecraft a alien visitors
extraterrestrial contact um I I just
don't see the extraordinary evidence uh
or the fingers of the cover up that one
would expect if that was the in fact the
case well so what's interesting there is
that he's you know in my mind I think
that there is a cover up of specific
knowledge of this kind of activity and
uh and this
technology and so he his the position
that he's taking is like relatively
moderate but it just it's a common sense
position which is that we know this
technology exists we we can see it like
it's a
fact we know that there's stuff going on
in the in the skies involving um craft
involving
technology that that far exceeds our own
understanding of what is even
possible
um and we know that and it's it's just
it's it
it it's a fact that it and it should
matter to people people should care
about it diversify your savings with
physical precious metals while
stockpiling silver in your home safe
with Birch gold group's most popular
special of the year now through December
22nd for every $5,000 you spend with
Birch gold they'll send you a 1o silver
eagle coin for free text wall to 9898 98
to claim your eligibility now you can
purchase gold and silver and have it
shipped directly to your home or have
Birch Gold's precious metal Specialists
help you convert an existing Ira or 401K
into a tax sheltered Ira in gold for no
money out of pocket they'll send you
free silver for every $5,000 you
purchase keep it for yourself or give
something with real value as a stocking
stuff for this year just text the word
Walsh to 9898 98 to claim your
eligibility with an A+ rating with a
Better Business Bureau and thousands of
happy customers now is the best time to
buy gold from Birch gold text Walsh to
98 9898 and claim your eligibility for
free silver on qualifying purchases
before December 2nd that's Walsh to 98
9898 and this book that he's got I don't
know anything else about this guy he's
got this book it should be this could be
it should be a big number one
bestseller and it probably won't be
that's the bad news I have for him spent
all his time writing a
book uh and uh and he probably thinks oh
this is this is a bombshell this the
best s No One's Gonna buy it Garrett I
hate to tell you I will I'll be your One
customer like nobody else
cares they should but they don't I I was
thinking about this today that because
of course I think about this topic every
day that I think if not for the sort of
like paradoxically if not for the
internet and social media people would
care a lot more about this
stuff that because it's always
interesting when you go
back and you look at the famous uh UFO
sightings from back in like the 50s 60s
70s 80s even the
90s and you go back and you you you
watch uh you know a documentary or an
unsolved mystery about one of those and
one thing you always notice is that it's
all over the news people were talking
about it it was like a big deal at the
time front page Headline News Right top
above the
fold and um aside from what they're
reporting like that to me aside from
from the the UFO itself that is like the
second most shocking
thing so when you look back then people
really cared about
this me there was like credible
reports of unexplained phenomena in the
skies this there's an intense amount of
public interest why is there public
interest because it's like it's Above
All Above everything else there's public
interest because it's interesting it's
an interesting thing to talk about and
think
about there's mystery there's there's
you know Wonder there's all these these
deep questions of our place in the
universe and of the universe itself
that's
interesting and that's how
people used to see these kinds of
stories but now in the social and you
would think if you didn't know any
better and you had to predict you would
think that the internet and social media
would just throw that into hyperdrive
because now we're seeing all this stuff
all the time and there'd be you know
there be there'd be even more interest
but it's had the opposite
effect I think because people are so
it's just we're there's so much
information coming out of all the time
and everybody is
numb and so when you have things like
this that are
fascinating everyone just kind of yawns
and turns
away and leaves me to talk about it
alone on a podcast that everyone has
already now turned off because I started
talking about this
again hey YouTube thanks for listening
to the show if you'd like access to my
full show with no ads you should go to
dailywire.com and use promo code Walsh
to get two months free on all annual
plans see you there